[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition or the SVD
and how you can approximate a matrix X
by a low rank matrix approximation which
is the product of U times Sigma times V
transpose more importantly you can take
this SVD and you can truncate it at some
desired rank R which is much less than
the dimensions of the original data
matrix X and often times depending on
the data these low rank representations
this truncated SVD still does a good job
of approximating the original data
matrix but this begs the question how do
you choose the truncation value R for
this SVD on a case-by-case basis okay so
mathematically we discussed the gavage
Donoho optimal hard threshold paper that
discusses how you can determine an
optimal rank truncation assuming that
your data is contaminated by Gaussian
white noise and so today I'm gonna code
this up in MATLAB and we're gonna
analyze how this actually works and how
to actually use their code I will point
out that they put their code up online
in a MATLAB file and so I'm going to be
using a piece of their code that
computes kind of the hard part of this
optimal threshold and we're gonna wrap
our code around that okay good so again
as I always want to point out when
you're developing a mathematical
technique or you're testing an algorithm
it's good to test it out on a case where
you know the answer first before
applying it to real data where you don't
know the answer okay and so here what
we're gonna do is we're gonna cook up a
data matrix X which is exactly a low
rank matrix we're gonna add Gaussian
white noise and we're gonna see how the
gavage Donoho criterion works in
identifying the true low rank subspace
okay and so in particular what we're
gonna do is we're going to have an X
matrix that is composed of two columns
times two rows so it's definitely going
to be a rank two matrix there will be
exactly two linearly independent rows
and columns and then I'm going to add a
bunch of Gaussian white noise onto that
that matrix and we're gonna see what the
gavage Donoho criterion tells us
be the ideal rank when we know that the
ideal rank should be to our equals two
so let's make it obvious that the actual
rank of the system is R equals two in
this case
okay good and so in this case what we're
gonna do is we're gonna cook up these
these true.you modes and true V modes
maybe this is a rank yeah I think this
is a rank two matrix exactly there's a
cosine a decaying cosine and a sine a
decaying sine and a cosine and I have
two singular values Sigma 1 and Sigma 2
are two and point five and so I'm going
to build my a trick my matrix by just
multiplying them and I'm going to plot
the plot that matrix okay so this is the
true clean data matrix it has rank two
and we cooked it up this is before
adding noise okay so you can see that
there's kind of this nice pattern of
sines and cosines and there's kind of
this like exponential Gaussian looking
bump in the middle yeah it's an
exponential of minus T squared so it's a
Gaussian okay so I have a Gaussian
envelope multiplying this sine and
cosine next what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to add white noise this R and n
matrix a whole nother matrix I'm gonna
add that to my data matrix and we're
gonna have our noisy data okay so this
is the data that we see that our
algorithm is going to see we know the
answer because we cooked up the data to
have a rank two structure but this is
the data that we're actually gonna feed
in to the Gammage Donoho algorithm to
see what the rank should be given this
noisy data okay and it's really quite
simple to compute this so the first
thing we do is we compute the SVD of our
noisy data okay and we get some singular
value distribution we will essentially
determine the hard threshold tau
remember we're going to we're going to
truncate all singular values J Sigma J
that are less than tau gets set equal to
0 so that's how we're going to determine
the rank of what we truncate and throw
away is any Sigma is less than
the stress hold Tao which I'm calling
cut off here in 125 and this is using
this the simplest most standard
formulation in the gavage Donahoe paper
it's 4 over the square root of 3 times
the square root of our square matrix
dimension n times the known amount of
noise Sigma so if you know the amount of
noise you can compute this threshold now
what I'm doing is I'm finding the rank R
is basically the number of elements of
Sigma that are larger than the cutoff
that's the rank I keep and then my clean
my D noised matrix is just going to be
the first R columns of U the first R by
R of Sigma and the first R columns of V
multiplied together so we're going to
identify remember the picture is that we
have some singular values with some
noise and we're going to figure out what
the noise distribution would have been
and only keep the singular values that
are larger than that noise distribution
that's what is in this this clean matrix
here and so if I run that this is what
the gavest Donoho optimal cleaned matrix
looks like and you can tell that it's
actually way yeah it's pretty good it's
way better than this noisy data it
actually does a really good job of
capturing the basic features of the
clean data and just for contrast I also
thought it would be nice to show if we
decided to truncate naively just to keep
the first 90% of the variance of the
data so we want to keep our this is what
people used to do is often you'd pick R
so that you capture 90 or 95 or 99% of
the variance of your data so here we're
gonna devise this our 90 threshold so
that we pick all of them that are the
capture 90% of the energy and I'm gonna
show you what that filtered data looks
like and you can see that if you go
based on this naive energy criterion I'm
just trying to capture 90% of the
variance of this noisy data you actually
do a really poor job of denoising
because most of those singular values
are below the noise threshold so the
optimal threshold gavage Donoho
threshold is really the right way at
least in this case where we have
white noise added to a low rank matrix
of optimally cleaning this this data
matrix and they actually prove that this
is as good of a low-rank approximation
as you can get that will faithfully
represent the the clean D noise data
okay good and then just to show what the
singular values look like in this case
so here are a couple of plots I find
interesting so here we're looking at the
singular value spectrum and a zoom in
and then the cumulative energy so let me
just make these a little bit bigger so
what we see here is the actual SVD the
the singular value distribution of the
noisy data matrix X and you can see that
I'm zooming in here to just the first
few singular values so the the blue
dashed line is essentially the threshold
that's determined by the gavage Donoho
criterion and only the blue circles are
the two modes that are captured that are
above that noise floor so here in the
zoom and you can see that there's only
exactly two modes that are above the
noise floor and everything else gets
discarded by this truncation and you can
tell actually that the remainder of this
singular value plot actually looks like
the SVD of a noise distribution and
that's really the idea going on behind
this this optimal hard threshold and
then over here you can actually see the
the total energy the cumulative energy
plot also versus the modes and you can
see that the first two singular values
that are kept by gavest Donoho actually
have a tiny tiny amount of the energy of
the data matrix because there's so much
noise on top of that and so if you only
go based on energetics and you keep
ninety percent of the of the energy
you're getting hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of noise modes and you're not
doing a good job of filtering okay good
so that shows that this algorithm works
in a case where we absolutely know the
answer where it definitely should work
because that's the case that they have
provable optimality but what I think is
really cool about this this truncation
criteria is that it even works in cases
where
data is not characterized that nicely by
low rank structure plus white noise so
we're going to go back to our eigen
faces example so we're gonna load all
faces we're gonna compute the SVD of
that it's probably gonna take a little
while so I'm gonna get that started and
then what we're gonna do is we're going
to plot the singular value distribution
we're gonna look at where the gavest on
a how hard threshold is how many modes
would be kept or not and then we're
gonna look at I in faces that are let's
say that we're gonna look at I gain
faces that are clearly in the low rank
part of the matrix the the clean part
that's right on the borderline of the
gavage Donahoe truncation and eigenfaces
way below gavage Donoho and we're gonna
see if this criterion actually does a
good job of separating this data matrix
into information that you want to keep
an information that you want to discard
okay so I'm just gonna run all of this
code it's a pretty big code it's going
to compute we've computed the SVD again
in this case we don't know what the
noise singular the noise magnitude is so
you have to use the more complicated
formulation where you compute the aspect
ratio of beta and you compute the
threshold using their formula from their
paper this is optimal SV HD coefficient
is from the original gavage Donahoe
paper so you can download that and use
it and let's see what we have here okay
good so here we have the singular value
distribution this is just the SVD of our
eigenfaces matrix and in the yellow line
what you can see is the gavage Donoho
optimal hard threshold and what I'm
showing in these three red dots those
are going to be eigen faces that are
above at and below this threshold so
we're gonna plot those and we're gonna
look at what they you know what these
faces look like and hopefully this will
do a good job
I've actually segmenting out the data so
I want to just bring this up okay this
one
this one and this one okay I hope you
can see this and this is our singular
value distribution okay so this is an
eigen face that's clearly above the
gavage Donoho threshold so this is the
first red dot and there's clearly eye
ghen face structure in there this is
definitely a good a good mode that's
informative and I'm gonna zoom into
these a little bit so you can see a
little bit better this is a mode that is
right right on that borderline of being
truncated so this one is just at the
border of truncation and this one is in
the noise floor at least according to
this gavage Donoho criterion and so what
I think is really amazing
is that this face the first red dot has
clear structure the second face which is
right right on this borderline you can
faintly see there is kind of the mask of
eyes nose and mouth in this but it's
really on the borderline and then if you
go below the scavenge Donoho threshold
what you see is essentially just white
noise maybe with the very faintest hint
of a face in there and so even though
this this matrix does not have any of
the kind of criteria and necessarily
that went into this mathematical proof
of optimality the gavage Donoho criteria
actually still does a pretty excellent
job of telling you where to chop off
your data to get actual structure and to
throw away the noise okay thank you